I don't think there is any occasion
isn't appropriate for like if there is I
don't go to it today we're talking to
Alexander Wang about styling all black
outfits we'll be talking about the
textures proportions and accessories
that keep all black fits interesting
Black has been a cornerstone of
Alexander Wang's brand and personal
style so Alex why the black in my
personal side I'd say that it's just
it's easy it's versatile and what I'm
going to work or I'm going to gym where
I'm going out right after work or you
know I'm going to another kind of
meeting I think a black t-shirt or a
black pair of jeans kind of really
essentially you can kind of win in any
situation with that most situations I
think in work as well it just creates
this attitude immediate attitude you
know when I look at something in black
and I think it's also kind of like a
blank slate when I do use color or print
things like that there has to be a
really strong purpose and reason and
story why I'm using fuchsia or turquoise
we're not a colorful brand with black
it's kind of like the canvas it's just
you know it's it's kind of what really
wraps up the entire kind of emotionality
around what our brand stands for I think
the best way to wear all black is to
really mix up your textures and your
proportions so what are textures and how
do you pair them texture I mean I mean
I'm wearing black jersey and black denim
and charcoal socks right now today I did
decide to wear leopard Leopard pony are
shoes usually I'm wearing kind of like
black sneakers or things like that it's
not that I always feel like there has to
be an injection of something of a print
or something humorous or you know
unexpected in that kind of outside of
black but I do think it really is about
how you wear it I think a good pair of
black jeans you know are really
important and kind of a great kind of
universal piece to have and the
proportions how about those I mean
obviously it applies differently for
each person I think it's really about
knowing your body type and kind of how
to wear certain kinds of archetypes or
materials that kind of exemplify your
attitude and your Sensibility I tend to
wear things a little bit looser a little
bit more oversized because I do like
things that feel a little bit more
offbeat a little bit more casual in
every situation so even my blazer
are a bit more unstructured you know my
pants are a little bit looser the crotch
is a little bit more dropped I think it
really depends who the person is
sometimes black can feel very strict
very buttoned up you know whether you
know wearing a tight black turtleneck
and kind of leggings and things like
that which is also something that we've
done in the brand but kind of how you
layer it up and you know throwing kind
of a big sweater or a big kind of you
know cardigan or a jacket over it really
kind of changes that attitude
immediately I
I never like to to dictate because I
just don't think there's any rules
anymore you know there really aren't you
know like I I might say that right now
and somebody you might come in and a
skin-tight black outfit and I'd be like
oh she looks great so how do you
accessorize I'm really into gold well I
was a very a silver person now I'm very
into gold as I get older so maybe that's
it question of myself honestly there's
never been an occasion where I felt like
oh my gosh you know like is all black
too much I didn't follow the
instructions today by the way they told
me specifically not to wear black and of
course just by default I throw on black
and it came here and someone on my team
reminded me that I didn't listen